[Musique]
sur ce terrain mohamid walkbrouk
construit sa future maison ce lopin de
terre d'un demi hectare ne lui a rien
coûté à Barbuda la terre est une
propriété collective elle ne peut être
ni acheter ni vendu j'ai eu ce terrain
en faisant une demande auprès du Conseil
de Barbuda
parcelle que vous voulez vous remplissez
quelques formulaires et elle est à vous
et c'est gratuit les premiers habitants
de Barbuda des Africains réduits en
esclavage avaient apporté avec eux leur
tradition à l'abolition en 1834 les
barboudiens ont été purement et
simplement oubliés par la Couronne
britannique ils se sont organisés pour
gérer collectivement les terres comme le
faisait leurs ancêtres en 2007 cet état
de fait a été inscrit dans la loi avec
le Land Act
et photographe comme les autres
habitants de l'île il avait tout perdu
en 2017 après le passage de l'ouragan
Irma ce cyclone l'un des plus violents
jamais enregistrés avait détruit une
grande partie de Barbuda je vous la
décrirai comme la pire nuit qu'il soit
possible de traverser dans sa ville
avant vécu Irma il y avait des vents
hurlants comme vous n'avez jamais
entendu auparavant
c'était terrifiant
au lendemain de l'ouragan le
gouvernement avait ordonné l'évacuation
de tous les habitants vers Antigua l'île
principale de cet état archipel ce
traumatisme est encore dans toutes les
mémoires
de personnes après que lors d'évacuation
a été émue
pendant 6 semaines les barbesiens ont
été interdits de rentrer chez eux la
plupart sont partis en bateau certains
sont partis en avion
pourtant les habitants n'attendaient
qu'une chose revenir pour reconstruire
leur île depuis 2018 le Premier ministre
Gaston Brown essaie d'introduire la
propriété privée à Barbuda il veut faire
de l'île un paradis pour touriste
fortuné quand nous sommes rentrés à
Barbuda il y avait déjà des ouvriers sur
des chantiers c'est l'un des problèmes
comme personne n'était là il pouvait
faire plus ou moins ce qu'il voulait le
groupe américain plage est un train de
construire au nord de Barbuda plus de
400 villas de luxe avec des lagons
artificiels et un parcours de golf
l'activiste John masington a tenu à nous
montrer comment pyl Edge privatise
discrètement l'une des plus belles
plages de l'île ce checkpoint est au
milieu d'une voie publique c'est cette
route qui va vers la plage donnez-moi
vos noms on ne peut pas vous laisser
entrer il vous faut une autorisation
après quelques minutes de négociation la
sécurité menace d'appeler la police je
porte plainte combien une photo de
l'emplacement de leur véhicule les
accusations de John nothington dérange
violation de domicile maintenant on est
juste en train de discuter la police
arrive on va les laisser régler ça les
investisseurs étrangers ne peuvent pas
acheter de terre sur l'île le conseil de
Barbuda leur loue une parcelle pour une
période de 50 ans mais l'autorité du
Conseil est remise en cause par le
gouvernement d'Antigua ce que le
gouvernement essaie de nous dire
c'est que notre système de propriété
collective
empêche tout développement
et que si nous voulons développer
Barbuda nous devons commencer à
autoriser les transactions foncières
quand on ouvre à la concurrence un
marché comme celui-là la valeur d'une
propriété augmente au point de devenir
inabordable pour les habitants de
Barbuda
l'acteur Robert De Niro a racheté en
2015 le bail de cette ancienne hôtel
détruit par Irma le gouvernement
d'Antigua lui aurait promis de devenir
propriétaire de ce terrain de plus de
100 hectares en bord de mer si le Land
Act était révoqué
promesse tenue en 2018 alors que la
population est encore dispersée à la
suite de l'ouragan Irma le Land actes
est annulé depuis les barbudiens peuvent
acheter au gouvernement leur terrain
pour 1 dollar symbolique seul une
centaine d'habitants à accepter cette
procédure avec une réforme du système
des terres communautaire quand les
habitants ne peuvent acheter un terrain
des millionnaires vont acheter cette
plage ils mettront des grilles de 3
mètres de haut les bords ne pourront
plus acheter ici donc nous serons
exclusion
après plusieurs procès en appel la
révocation du Land actes a été ratifiée
par la plus haute cour de justice
d'Antigua et Barbuda en juin dernier
mais le Conseil veut maintenant plaider
sa cause devant la Cour internationale
de justice
depuis le début de cette crise politique
le gouvernement d'Antigua a divisé par
deux le budget du Conseil
le gouvernement met en oeuvre une
stratégie délibérée pour appauvrir la
population
c'est ce qu'ils veulent mais ça
n'arrivera pas
la résistance s'organise depuis Barbuda
sur Internet John nothington a découvert
d'autres communautés qui défendent la
propriété collective tout seul assis ici
je ne peux pas me battre contre les
milliardaires
mais en créant des connexions avec
d'autres activités obélisent en Jamaïque
en Angleterre et partout dans le monde
nous sommes capables de trouver des
ressources pour faire entendre notre
voix
les communautés autochtones luttent pour
sauvegarder la propriété collective en
2016 un rapport d'Oxfam estimait que 2,5
milliards de personnes dépendaient de
terre communautaire